[Música]
la gran familia del bid o la familia
afecto no completo
[Música]
y
no
[Música]
a
qué tal cómo están bienvenidos a su
programa canadá en las américas cafés
con el gusto de siempre que les damos la
bienvenida a este programa que podríamos
también llamar canadá en aislamiento
voluntario porque estamos viviendo de
cerca los efectos de el coronavirus del
cobi 19 como también se le llama gracias
por acompañarnos donde quiera que se
encuentren los saludamos aquí desde
nuestros estudios en la ciudad de
montreal yo me llamo paloma martínez y
aquí en el estudio están de honduras
armando laguna hola a todos
leonardo gimeno que tal buenos días
pablo gómez barrios un saludo para todos
los que están allá del otro lado y
buenos días y buenas tardes y buenas
noches nos vemos aquí ahora nos están
viendo así que saludamos a todos
aquellos que nos estén siguiendo por
cualquier medio que lo estén haciendo
por facebook lite por youtube live por
nuestro sitio internet www.sprint.com
por acompañarnos hoy en el programa
vamos a tratar de clarificar algunas de
las de los cuestionamientos de las
preocupaciones de la gente en relación
con el coronavirus porque claro las
cosas han ido evolucionando muy rápido
en los últimos días y nosotros le hemos
estado viviendo de cerca así que no sé
si tiene algo que comentar sobre esto
qué es esto además es como una especie
de tensión que está aumentando en todo
el mundo los primeros ministros los
presidentes de todo el mundo salen hacen
discursos donde dicen explica la
situación de cada país cómo se va
desarrollando extendiendo este virus y
las medidas que hay que tomar entonces
causa un poco como diría yo como un poco
de temor no sobre todo y por eso me
parece importante programas como este
donde justamente hay que dejar de lado
los correos electrónicos los facebook
que uno recibe y prestar atención a lo
que dice la ciencia exacto
la única manera de que uno reciba una
información confiable segura exactamente
y por eso tenemos hoy en invitada
especial que le vamos a presentar en un
momentito más y es una microbióloga
especialista de este tipo de temas
justamente de la universidad de calgary
se llama marie claire arrieta pero pablo
quiere decir algo al respecto primero
y no decía quería agregar simplemente de
que con respecto a la información como
decía leonora lo que sucede también es
que mucha gente se informa a través de
las redes sociales y es justamente ahí
en donde está el problema porque todo
tipo de circulación de información
circula y bueno pues entonces pues puede
confundir a la gente buena y mala
información no entonces no cabe duda
además que esté coronavirus se ha dejado
sentir los efectos de esta presencia del
virus se han dejado sentir en todas
partes del mundo en todos los diferentes
ámbitos de la vida en el deporte en la
cultura cuantos eventos deportivos
cuántos eventos culturales no han sido
ya exactamente las escuelas acaban de
ser celebradas aquí en quebec ayer se
cerraron en el parlamento canadiense a
partir de mañana ya está cerrado lo
cerró las puertas exactamente y usted
entró el primer ministro de canadá acaba
de anunciar medidas específicas con
respecto a la entrada ya la salida de
gente en los aeropuertos en las
fronteras del país entonces mucho hacer
muchos efectos y aquí en esta casa donde
hay muchos programas de radio
y de televisión con público también
cancelaron al público a partir de hoy ni
se van a llevar a cabo los programas
pero sin público y tenemos que decir por
supuesto que el primer ministro
canadiense está aislado con su mujer y
sus hijos porque su mujer dio positivo
en el test del coronavirus entonces
bueno todas las medidas están llegando
que se contagió en londres exactamente
viajando en lo estuvo de en una
conferencia en londres y al volver se
dio cuenta que tenía algunos síntomas de
gripe que se asemejan a la gripe a y
entonces a partir de ahí comenzaron a
tomar las medidas necesarias haciendo
las pruebas necesarias y bueno dio
positivo y ahora hay que esperar para el
resto de la familia pero están aislados
igualmente entonces están haciendo lo
que se debe hacer final prácticamente
vamos a hablar entonces con marie-claire
arrieta ahora sí se las presentó qué tal
mariel marie claire como está
y ya no le escuchamos pero ahora sí como
estoy bien estoy muy bien por ti
muchísimas gracias por la invitación
encantado les decía que marie claire
arrieta es microbióloga de la
universidad de calgary marie claire
comencemos con la pregunta que todo el
mundo se está haciendo debemos comenzar
a entrar en pánico o no con respecto al
coronavirus por supuesto que no y nunca
vemos a no serlo ni ahora ni mañana en
ningún momento el pánico es obviamente
una respuesta
primal de muchísimas animales incluyendo
los seres humanos pero es una de las
respuestas
que menos nos va a ayudar en este caso
una de las ventajas es que tenemos
muchísima información entonces accesar
esta información puede ayudarnos a
regular ya está esa respuesta intuitiva
de asustarnos y convertirla en cifras e
información oportuna y efectiva ahora
justamente que sabemos el coronavirus
que es la información más reciente que
se tiene al respecto como cómo reacciona
con qué
de este virus entonces marc y claro en
cuanto a la biología lo que el virus
causa en el ser humano es que es un
virus que se transmite bastante bastante
fácil como muchos virus que atacan las
vías respiratorias y la razón de esto es
que todos respiramos por supuesto y al
estar enfermos
hacemos esto rodamos y normalmente lo
hacemos cubriéndonos o transmitiendo
todas estas partículas a nuestras manos
entonces es muy fácil pasarla a otras
superficies oa otras personas
entonces se transmite muy fácil la
segunda cosa que conocemos es que tiene
una variedad de síntomas en la mayoría
de las personas no va a causar una
enfermedad grave pero este iba a causar
síntomas que nos van a hacer que nos
sintamos enfermos y estos síntomas en
general es la fiebre es el síntoma más
común además de la tos una tos seca que
también puede ser acompañada con un poco
de crema con en algunos casos dificultad
para respirar y también con letargia o
cansancio ahora estos son los síntomas
más más normales más más conocidos en la
mayoría de las personas pero sí claro
pero al mismo tiempo hay personas que
también reportan otros tipos de síntomas
que estamos que relacionamos a las otras
gripes como el dolor de cabeza el dolor
de músculos son huesos eso también puede
pasar ahora esto está en alrededor del
80% de las personas pero hay un 20% de
las personas que van a experimentar más
gravedad en los síntomas y un 5% de las
personas va a tener síntomas sus signos
y niko en muy severos y esto va a
representar no sólo que vayan a
necesitar ayuda médica y un hospital
sino que van a necesitar
y cuidados críticos en el hospital eso
significa que no pueden estar nada más
en cualquier parte del hospital sino una
zona donde tengan el equipo tanto para
el equipo médico como el equipo de
máquinas y de intervenciones que los
hagan poder poder subsistir
artificiales lo que también se dice es
que hay un 5% de las personas afectadas
para las cuales es a ese virus va a
significar mucho sufrimiento y tal vez
inclusive lleve a la muerte qué pasa qué
pasa una persona cualquiera que se hace
la pregunta cuando tengo que ir al
hospital cuando tiene una persona que ir
al hospital
a partir de qué momento
la mayoría de las ciudades en canadá si
no es que todas ya tienen una serie de
reglas que indican que hay que informar
a una línea telefónica cuando se están
sintiendo estos síntomas por ejemplo yo
estoy encargaría quien está a algar y el
número es el 811 es un número que si hay
un poco de espera 15-20 minutos pero uno
habla con una enfermera le comunica que
tiene alguno de estos síntomas y la
manera como se ha organizado por lo
menos acá es que envían a un personal de
salud a la casa a hacer el test cuando
indican que uno es candidato a ser
electas y además está en comunicación
con uno para ver cómo sigue cómo siguen
los síntomas de por supuesto en
en el momento en que las vías
respiratorias se vean super
comprometidas y las personas tengan
dificultades para respirar por su piel y
no responda por ejemplo al tratamiento
normal del acetaminofén es una
indicación que tiene que buscar ayuda
médica pero cada una aquí el consejo
importante es que cada ciudad y cada
provincia va a tener reglas alcohol
oberto y que y que uno tiene que estar
informado de cuál es este protocolo para
saber cómo comunicar el sistema de salud
o quien no tiene esos síntomas y no nada
más y directamente al hospital yo según
tengo entendido el 811 funciona en todo
canadá en todo el territorio o por lo
menos en gran parte del territorio
canario aunque hoy justamente el primer
ministro de québec dijo que esa línea
estaba completamente saturada entonces
propuso a la gente otro número de
teléfono a la que la gente de aquí en la
en la provincia de québec puede que
puede utilizar entonces es el 1 877 6 44
45 45
1 877 6 44 45 45 aquí en la ciudad de
montreal en la provincia de québec en
particular pero claro si uno va al sitio
internet de de salud canadá de health
canada os ante canadá pueden encontrar
la información para cada una de las
provincias si tienen dudas con respecto
a su salud también está el sitio de
radio canadá estuve mirando tiene
muchísima información cuando acudir en
qué casos de según los síntomas son
médicos mis largos que dan esos consejos
en civil si entonces si yo creo que hay
bastante información que está siendo
difundida habla que habría que hacer
entonces si tú llamas por ejemplo al 811
y está completamente desbordado
cuál es el consejo que hay que darle a
la gente aparte de este teléfono que lo
que dicen es que hay una espera de todas
maneras de 15 minutos por lo menos pero
mi hermano exactamente pero se
recomendaría alguna otra cosa marie
claire es que cada provincia va a tener
un protocolo distinto lo que sí me
cuesta metiéndome ahora en aire
el éxito es que existe uno acá ahora me
cuesta tipo de menos en en alberta
pusieron más personas y más enfermeras y
enfermeros a tratar de solventar el
problema de que por supuesto estas
líneas están saturadas pero si yo lo que
recomendaría es buscar fuentes de
información oficiales de cada provincia
porque recuerda recordando que los
sistemas de salud los gobiernos los
sistemas de salud funciona a nivel
promedio provincial en canadá entonces
recurrir a la página oficial y seguir
los lineamientos que nos indiquen
yo tengo una pregunta con respecto al
protocolo de manera general por parte
del gobierno canadiense que es y de los
diferentes gobiernos provinciales que es
lo que está tratando de hacer en este
momento en todo el sistema de salud
pública del país con respecto a
la transmisión del virus en el país
porque lo que se sustenta en cerrando
escuelas están cerrando guarderías están
tratando de mantener a la gente lo más
posible en sus casas porque están
haciendo eso cuál es la razón de todas
estas acciones
bueno en cuestión de salud pública las
dos medidas que funcionan en situaciones
de epidemia por supuesto de pandemias
como éstas son para enfermedades
respiratorias son en distanciamiento
social y like tiene estos son los dos
factores más importantes en esta vida ni
aunque nada más tiene dos meses y medio
digamos despreciando estudiar se han
obtenido datos importantes y se sabe
cuando estas medidas se toman
efectivamente el nivel de contagio
disminuye entonces estas son las dos
medidas distanciamiento social e higiene
y eso fue lo que no hicieron en otros
gobiernos en otros países del mundo
porque estamos hablando con usted estoy
viendo que 250 nuevos nuevos muertes en
italia acaban de ser anunciadas en 24
horas entonces qué es lo que pasó en
otros países
que no queremos que pase así básicamente
tiene que ver con la ventana de tiempo
en la cual se empiezan a tomar estas
decisiones simples porque se conoce pues
cuando esté bien es el efecto de la
curva de transmisión y la curva de
contagio y por supuesto en el caso de
países como italia donde se tomaron un
poco más tarde estamos viendo muchísimas
más muertes porque los centros de salud
están sobresaturados entonces por
ejemplo si son un 5 a 10 por ciento de
estos pacientes graves que requieren
tratamientos críticos una mayor
proporción de estas personas no va a
salir de esta enfermedad o probablemente
va a morir porque no existen los medios
para atenderlos entonces lo que estamos
viendo entonces eventualmente muy
probable que muchos de nosotros vayamos
a ser contagiados por el coronavirus lo
que no queremos es contagiar nos todos
en la misma semana queremos remarcar en
que nos contagiemos para tratar de
ayudar a nuestro sistema de salud a que
la manera más eficiente pueda tomar los
cuidados necesarios para este porcentaje
de pacientes que sabemos se van a poner
graves y que sabemos que son en su gran
mayoría personas con factores de riesgo
de salud y personas mayores de 70 años
en realidad no queremos contagiar
igualmente según lo que yo escuché lo
que yo he leído en diferentes sitios de
internet de gobierno es muy probable que
haya de un 30 a un 60 por ciento de la
población de cada uno de los países
contagiados lo que pasa es que como
decía recién aquí en nuestra
especialista es justamente es como
cuando se da el contagio y tratar de
evitar que uno pueda ser atendido como
corresponde y bajando el contacto
bajando la salida bajando la frecuencia
esto puede ser importante bueno se está
viendo en chino en china
hoy hay menos casos activos que en
italia donde fue donde se donde nació la
historia es que
y ahí nació la historia pero lo que
estaba justamente la organización
mundial de la salud acaba de decretar
que el epicentro de la enfermedad ahora
se trasladó a europa y yo me pregunto
hasta ahora canadá está está llevando
bien en la cosa américa latina también
no hay tantos casos pero el hecho y
laprida la pregunta marie claire el
hecho de que en eeuu ya se esté hablando
de que va a ser también imparable en al
de alguna medida en los contagios la
extensión de este virus va a ser de
manera que este virus llegue más a
américa latina inclusive a canadá existe
esa posibilidad
si existe esa posibilidad existe la
posibilidad de que eeuu y que otros
países o que cualquier otro país no
tenga el mejor manejo en cuanto a los
lineamientos epidemiológicos de cuando
verdaderamente tomar medidas drásticas
el problema saldo de más grave en este
momento en eeuu pero seguro escucho hoy
puede que cambie y aquí a mañana es que
no hay suficiente tasa de exámenes que
se están haciendo a nivel de la
población por diferentes decisiones de
sus instituciones de salud y sus
instituciones políticas la población no
está suficiente ustedes que se estén
haciendo entonces dependemos muchísimo
de esta información de cuántas personas
sabemos que están infectadas y cuánto no
para tomar esas decisiones de celular a
escuelas etcétera ahora aunque este
mensaje puede ser un propio un poco
preocupante hay condados en estados
unidos que ya sabiendo esta información
están tomando las medidas drásticas
entonces no están dependiendo de los
datos oficiales
cuántos espacios hay para decir el
condado cerro sus escuelas por supuesto
decisiones muy difíciles porque a nivel
social esto tiene repercusiones super
importantes para muchísimas de las
personas que trabajan y que tienen hijos
en las escuelas es algo que italia vivió
en esta última última semana pero que
también nos da el ejemplo que se puede
hacer tiene repercusiones pero se puede
hacer y son medidas efectivas una última
pregunta para usted' marie claire
vimos que la provincia de ontario y la
provincia de québec decidieron cerrar
las escuelas por lo menos dos o tres
semanas en el caso de ontario que está
pasando que está haciendo en alberta
particularmente hay alguna medida
específica que es eso que sobresalga
hasta ayer prohibieron las reuniones
públicas de más de 250 personas además
dieron consejos de quedarse en casa
cuando sea posible y por supuesto a la
pregunta de los periodistas de si van a
asegurar escuelas es algo que están
considerando en alberta hay menos casos
oficiales son mucho más es que se
estaban haciendo aquí en otras
provincias yo lo que creo que va a pasar
como ha pasado en esta última semana es
que vamos a escuchar esta noticia si no
hay probablemente el lunes o el martes
yo tengo una pregunta en él con respecto
a por qué esto se sabe que o por lo
menos se sospecha fuertemente que nació
de el ámbito animal y que se pasó al ser
humano y ahora se contagia entre humanos
hermanos hay alguna posibilidad de que
las mascotas porque la gente aquí en
canadá tiene muchas mascotas qué pasa
con las mascotas se puede transmitir
este vídeo a una mascota que colin cuál
es la probabilidad
de que esto sea su inicio un reporte
donde se descubrió el virus en la nariz
de un perro es el único reporte que
existe ahora hay que tener cuidado a la
hora de interpretar este reporte porque
si yo le hago un test a una superficie
que alguien contagia o acaba de
y infeccioso acaba de tocar esto
entonces también va a salir positivo
hasta el momento y sé que en china han
hecho estudios de esto han tomado
pruebas de suero de animales y no hay
reportes de animales ni enfermos ni
verdaderamente infectados y por supuesto
esto significa que no hay informes de
que de que esto se pueda transmitir por
animales que están en contacto con el
ser humano normalmente yo creo que ya se
descartó esa posibilidad de que se pueda
transmitir por intermedio de animales
creo haber leído en algún lugar puede
ser bueno muchísimas gracias marie
claire yo creo que todos nos quedamos un
poquito más tranquilo y marconi
duramente y si no tiene inconvenientes
volveremos a invitar porque esto es
muchísima información la que ellos
tienen exactamente importante
si pudiera agregar nada más algo muy
serio
a esta a esta curva con un concierto
importante de transmitir es que nos
compre tiempo porque algo muy real y da
una muy buena noticia a diferencia de
otro montón de epidemias es que la si
ya está avanzando increíblemente rápido
en cuanto a buscar tratamientos y
vacunas entonces entre entre más podamos
disminuir la tasa de contagio más
probabilidades de poder vacunar a las
personas y después darles una final u
otra droga que facilite y que me acuerde
la tasa de mortalidad yo había hecho
como trabajo para la casa un par de
anotaciones con respecto a las cosas que
ya sabemos y que son importantes las
buenas noticias con este virus y se sabe
cómo detectarlo en china la situación
mejora drásticamente el 80% de los casos
son leves la gente se cura casi no
afecta a menores de 20 años digo casi
porque hay casos de menores se inactiva
fácilmente en las superficies con
alcohol de 70% o con agua oxigenada o
con blanca jabón o con lavandina y
también hay más artistas de 150
artículos científicos que ya están dando
vuelta al mundo para ayudar a encontrar
una solución
ya hay prototipos de vacunas en abril se
supone que van a ver los primeros van a
existir los primeros test 80% de ensayos
clínicos con antivirales en curso hay
menos desplazamientos en avión en que
eso también la acb en el planeta y en
china la calidad del aire ha mejorado
muchísimo y esto es porque efectivamente
con estas reglas de no salir en la
polución ha disminuido y eso lo hace
súper bien el planeta también marie
claire argueta de nuevo muchísimas
gracias y pasas
marie claire hay mensajes acá de ligia
villalobos desde costa rica que dice que
estén muy bien juan carlos miranda
duarte saludos desde chile anselmo
delgado saludos desde mexico amigos de
radio canadá saludos desde nicaragua
pilar medina alejandro mendieta y en fin
ella lobos gustavo lucas juan carlos
miranda ya lo habíamos dicho y aki
miriam alarcón dice olas yo muy
preocupada de entrenar una compañía de
trabajo de mi hija que vino de europa y
fue a trabajar ahora tienen que esperar
para confirmar dice luego dios que mi
hija no se ha contagiado igual lo que yo
leía de una bióloga también que
explicaba en los medios de comunicación
es que justamente vamos a estar
expuestos a que algún familiar algún
amigo cercano algún compañero de trabajo
esté contagiado eso no significa que sea
mortal
lo importante es que si sabemos eso que
comemos la anilla de rápidamente
quedarnos en casa entonces ser ser mucho
más precavidos de lo que normalmente
seríamos si estamos resfriados casi
todos nosotros hemos amanecido
resfriados o con dolor de cabeza y nos
tomamos una pastilla y nos vamos a
trabajar esto lo que cambia ahora si nos
sentimos mal nos quedamos en la casa de
acuerdo
bueno pues muchísimas gracias de nuevo y
estaremos en contacto porque
probablemente que necesitemos que nos
ilustren nuevamente como informe vaya
avanzando porque esto cambia muy
rápidamente entonces gracias marie
claire gracias
si recordamos que marie claire arietes
microbióloga de la universidad de
calgary tiene un laboratorio anterior
de microbiología a su cargo y entonces
trabajan todo el día
todo el día exactamente vamos ahora a
ver un vídeo de la aplicación porque
hacen
y entonces cuando leonardo puedes
comenzar a hablar de esta maravillosa
aplicación mientras se cuenta en el
vídeo si la aplicación bueno es una
manera muy sencilla de tener todo el
contenido de radio canal internacional
en la palma de la mano
hablando de eso limpien sus teléfonos
también limpiar el teléfono sí sí sí una
superficie hay que lavarlo pero desea
limpiarlo limpiando bueno y la
aplicación puede ser conseguida en las
cinco lenguas y en las que radio canadá
internacional produce contenidos esto es
las dos lenguas oficiales francés inglés
y español árabe y chino nosotros
aconsejamos a nuestros orden test
buscarla en español por una cuestión de
que no se entiendan mejor así que están
en las tiendas más conocidas en apple
store
en google play así que para todos
aquellos que tengan bueno que les guste
el contenido que radio canadá
internacional produce a diario la
invitación es formal vayan y bajen la
aplicación de radio cara internacional
queremos saber cuánta gente le ha bajado
no tenga este momento podría ir a buscar
una información tengo en este momento lo
que sí se sabe es que en la sección
francesa tiene muchísima sección
francesa de que lea un punto de juez y
no si no me equivoco es la sección árabe
la que sigue la que más tiene que ver
también con la gente que lo use como se
usa no hay gente no en américa latina en
la gente que consulta los diarios según
lo que yo tengo entendido no tiene
aplicaciones buscan directamente a las
páginas de internet en este caso es una
manera mucho más fácil sí que les
recomendamos que vayan hagan clic en el
link que está en nuestra página de
internet o bien directamente y buscar
radio canadá internacional en español y
pueden bajar la aplicación que va a ser
mucho más fácil
bueno pues muy bien tenemos algún otro
mensaje por ahí que llegó leonardo
mientras marie claire se fue
juan carlos
miranda duarte es el nivel de contagio
en chile llega a 43 personas y 43
personas y la mayoría contagiados en
europa
gustavo lucas dice saludos desde la
ciudad de melo en uruguay gracias a
marie claire por su ilustrativa
explicación no tiene en uruguay por
ahora sin casos confirmados con los
amigos y después bueno saludos anselmo
delgado entonces todos
no no no pero a mí me parece importante
destacar el hecho de que la esta señora
que tuve y haya también una especialista
en radio canadá que vamos a estar
expuestos a encontrar gente todos los
días que estén contagiadas que tiene los
síntomas no hay que alarmarse hay que
tomar
las manos tomar las precauciones
necesarias para tocar lo menos posible
las superficies de otros públicos que
nos rodean
el papel higiénico también en la
fidelidad hay que decir que nos
estuvimos leyendo muchísimo y en el
trabajo porque es el tema del papel
higiénico
y estás mostrando unas imágenes que la
gente se ha vuelto loca loca loca hay un
negocio muy conocido para la gente que
nos mira desde américa latina se llama
el coco que es un mayorista es realmente
todo lo grande para vino la leche viene
en paquetes de 6 en las pizzas en
paquete de 12 todo grande en el coco no
y ayer voy a anteayer y ayer bueno en
casos de agresiones porque la gente sale
a correr hacia hasta este lugar a
comprar los paquetes que vienen de 40
rollos de papel higiénico y no hay más
hace dos días que en montreal no se
consigue papel higiénico hacer un
llamado
yo creo que todos estamos entrando en
cierta medida ya nos decía marie claire
que no es necesario que no entremos en
pánico yo creo que todos tenemos que
tener un poco una reserva de comida de
cualquier manera en nuestra casa de
latas de algunos productos esenciales
que tenemos que tener siempre pero eso
es el caso de que tengas que aislarte
exactamente no no hace falta siempre
dicen que hay que tener por lo menos
para 72 horas de cualquier manera ahora
todos tenemos dos horas por también agua
y lo demás lo que siento es que como la
gente me va y compra 27 30 paquetes de
pasta o de papel de baño
es que no deja para los demás claro al
alcohol y al jabón o sea uno dice en las
manos no tengo imágenes de lo que de lo
que se está viviendo la gente en los
supermercados en montreal ese es un chip
el mercado por el color puede ser martín
o por ciento es un supermercado
para ver es impresionante
entonces que no panda el cúnico sería
interesante cuál sería la explicación
que podría dar un psicólogo sobre el yo
había algo y no lo leí sobre él sobre
todo sobre el aspecto del papel
higiénico me interesaría saber por qué
si poca parte si bien es una de las
posibilidades debemos tener diarrea en
los primeros síntomas en casos extremos
que se tienen al mismo tiempo empecé me
parece ridículo
[Música]
y es innecesario yo creo que hay que
pensar en todo lo demás porque incluso
si uno digamos que tiene mucha pasta en
su casa y mucho papel de baño si hay
algo dramático no porque se salve uno se
salva el mundo entonces hay que pensar
en todos los que superimportante tanto
aquí no es una cuestión individual sino
social
exactamente bueno entonces así quedó el
tema del coronavirus por hoy aunque creo
que alguno de los temas que ustedes
presentan esta semana tiene que ver con
coronavirus si es una noticia sobre que
el parlamento canadiense decidió cerrar
sus puertas y entonces eso no pero tú
vas a presentar otro tema hablemos de tu
tema de la semana nuestra es otra cosa
vamos al tema de la semana y después
vamos al coronavirus un poco para dar un
poco de pausa
los nature nos hablas esta semana del
plan de inmigración canadiense el nuevo
plan tina es un nuevo plan que acaba de
entrar en vigor en el 2020 es un plan
quinquenal
del 2020 al 2025 es un plan ideal
presentado por el gobierno federal que
hizo que comprende a cinco provincias
canadienses que van a participar de
comunidades de cinco provincias
canadienses que están alejadas zonas
rurales y en el norte por ejemplo el
norte de ontario norte de manitoba estas
provincias son ontario manitoba
saskatchewan está columbia británica y
hay una que se me escapa a alberta la
razón es que esa es la población en esos
lugares alejados está estancada o
disminuyendo lo que está causando
problemas económicos en exa en todas
esas provincias
entonces conversamos con una experta en
inmigración ella se llama vilma phillips
y es una reconocida experta de más de 30
años en temas de inmigración ella nos
habló justamente de este plan quinquenal
y lo interesante de este plan y ella lo
recalca es que no es el gobierno federal
el que va a decidir quién va a
participar en ese pero en esos programas
quién puede venir
desde fuera de canadá sino las
comunidades que están organizadas ellos
saben lo que quieren y lo que necesitan
exactamente entonces ahí en este
reportaje que hemos hecho siempre se
busca la información sobre quiénes
pueden postular cuáles son los
requisitos que para este tipo de cosas
también la experta dice que buscan mano
de obra especializada y no especializada
para lo cual las exigencias son mucho
menores es decir a niveles de inglés por
ejemplo normalmente el gobierno federal
exige a cualquier inmigrante un nivel 7
de inglés o francés en este caso son de
va de 4 a 5 a 6 entonces es dependiendo
del trabajo entonces eso abre las
puertas a todo tipo de trabajadores y
después bueno en fin hay muchísima
información en esto y entonces se pueden
pueden entrar al sitio y ver lo que ella
también me gustó mucho que aclarar es
que cuando activo lo dice zonas rurales
son en realidad pequeñas ciudades de son
ciudades de cine
lo que pasa que están en zonas alejadas
de 50 habitantes a 100.000 habitantes
varían de una zona muy grande en zonas
con paisajes pues muy interesantes con
mucho trabajo y a lo que ella también
destaca es que en esas zonas lo que hay
que tener es ganas de ir a vivir en
regiones no en las grandes ciudades es
un gran desafío también para los
inmigrantes pero son grandes ciudades
están ahora en son ciudades que tienen
cuentan con sistemas de salud público
cuentan con universidades y que además
son más baratas que en las grandes
ciudades que han y ya por ejemplo decía
que una persona en toronto donde ella
vive una casa chica con dos dormitorios
no la consigue es por menos de 700 mil
dólares la misma casa en cualquiera de
esos lugares está 200 mil y menos y si
no quieres la verás también mucho más la
tasa mucho más baja entonces se puede
vivir perfectamente son lugares ideales
para criar a los hijos es muy tranquilo
entonces hay que querer vivir en eso
y hay muchas posibilidades y lo
interesante vía para terminar es que
ella nos dio como una especie de
primicia lo que ella dijo nos dio un
sitio donde uno puede entrar primero
entras al sitio están todas las
exigencias para poder participar en esos
programas entonces aparte de eso están
los dueños de las empresas mismos que
ponen sus sus sitios dentro de esos
sitios de web donde hay una persona
puede enviar directamente sucede al
saldo saludo su currículum a su
currículo sucede claro su currículum y
entrar en contacto directo con los
propiedades de las empresas pues bloquea
entonces todo esa información está en
este reportaje en www.sii.cl lo buscamos
como plan de inmigración canadá porque
ahí está directo 2020 2020 o 2025 exacto
y leonardo volviendo al coronavirus tú
si nos hablas de corona
exacto la computadora la más rápida que
existe hasta la fecha que es una
computadora se llama summit que
pertenece a ibm plantearon bueno con
informaciones recogidas de el gobierno
chino y de un montón de instituciones
pusieron a trabajar esta
supercomputadora con algoritmos para
descubrir para acelerar los procesos de
descubrimiento de elementos que puedan
ayudar a combatir tanto para en realidad
para cuando uno está enfermo para ayudar
en los tratamientos como para una vacuna
para evitar el contagio de coronarias en
este caso summit el supercomputadora de
la empresa ibm fue puesta al servicio y
encontró 77 compuestos de moléculas que
podrían ser posibles llaves para
combatir este nuevo virus así que nos
encontramos haciendo justamente el
trabajo de este algoritmo de algoritmos
que ponen sustancias y hacen
simulaciones en esto estuvo basado en
el último digamos paso que se conoce que
se tiene información exacta que es el
sars que es muy parecido entonces se
hicieron simulaciones con esto y
encontraron 777 llaves para poder de una
crisis que ya están digamos a
disposición de los equipos científicos
que están encargándose de encontrar una
cura de todos los gobiernos y de
universidades para ver si lo que decía
marie claire arrieta que las
colaboraciones y el avance es mucho más
rápido
si no me equivoco leonardo hubo hace
poco una noticia sobre que también a
través de computadoras se lograron estas
computadoras lograron crear una una que
o algo de detección de un cáncer mucho
más rápido o si no era detección de
cáncer si era el remedio para curar un
cáncer
no se lo voy a buscar lo veo que es una
computadora porque eso justamente es lo
que hacen estas súper computadoras es
que la capacidad de cómputo es mucho más
grande en el artículo dice efectivamente
que hubieran pasado años y una
computadora normal se hubiera puesto a
tratar de hacer estos cálculos para ver
las posibles de aves la capacidad
en el artículo no no me acuerdo dónde
exactamente pero pongo lo que significa
esta supercomputadora el tamaño
[Música]
bueno por ejemplo acá dice
summit es una computadora hasta ahora
más poderoso del mundo construida por
ibm compuesta por 4600 nodos nosotros en
computación no le llamamos a cada
computadora o sea cada procesador a4
dentro de la misma con cada uno tiene
600 gigas de memoria o sea es
impresionante el tamaño y la posibilidad
de cómputo es mucho mucho más acelerada
entonces logran resultados mucho más
rápidos que es lo que justamente ahora
se necesita y en el artículo también ibm
esta información del sitio de ibm
que no solamente ellos están con esta
iniciativa sino el laboratorio lawrence
livermore de eeuu que tiene la
supercomputadora sierra que es la
segunda más rápida también está haciendo
los mismos cálculos
lenovo e intel también se asociaron con
vg y para ofrecer ellos también este
tipo de servicios la unión europea
anunció que sus centros de
supercomputación también están
dispuestos a ayudar a investigadores
todo esto gratis para lograr encontrar
una solución rápida a este problema
muchas gracias leonardo soto van
encontrar ya desde desde hoy en el sitio
internet de radio canadá internacional y
pablo tú también nos habla de corona
muy rápidamente pero siempre desde el
punto de vista tecnológico como estaba
diciendo nuestro querido leonardo y el
un asistente una compañía de
un líder canadiense de cuidado de la
salud virtuales así entonces ellos
lanzaron se llama de dialog diálogo si
queremos llamarlo decirlo en español ese
es un lazo está este programa que se
llama cloud que permite a la gente
apoyándose en una en una lo que yo llama
tecnología conversacional aunque
leonardo la probé y no le funcionó la
probé desde la aplicación y la
aplicación funciona cuando está duro yo
quería charlar con él de esto que me
interesa y yo instale la aplicación para
explicación está ligada directamente a
las empresas que contraten el servicio
de verdad si entra uno en la página
internet funciona
exacto como individuo por la aplicación
no entonces lo en ella pues te pide
primero tienes que llenar un formulario
en el que vas a dar informaciones como
la ubicación los factores de riesgos
potenciales los antecedentes de viaje
condiciones médicas pre-existentes
etcétera y en función de eso cloud
te va a dar respuestas de lo que doy de
lo que podría ser de lo que podrías
hacer y te va a dar las últimas
informaciones y recursos disponibles al
público entonces ayuda a las personas
que entren ahí a ubicarse y de alguna
forma medir el estado de la situación al
que es el sin embargo tiene que ser esta
aplicación tiene que haber sido digamos
comprada por una por una empresa como
radio canadá o como uno funciona no es
disponible para el público en general y
es el está el sitio de internet el sitio
internet está disponible si el sitio
exacto sigue ahí puedes consultar a
chloe que te da la información y bueno
pues es un servicio gratuito
bien y tiene alguna relación con algún
gobierno es simplemente privado es un
servicio que ofrece esta compañía
exacto que creo para el caso del cobi 19
este programa
entiendo y bueno esta semana les
presento un reportaje sobre un estudio
que se hizo un informe de hecho que hizo
un organismo de beneficencia pública
pero mundial en el que hablan de la
salud y la protección de los animales y
parece ser que canadá salió reprobado
muy mal porque bueno muy mal entre
comillas porque con los pero siempre
mexicano más exactamente parece que en
cuanto a protección de animales las
leyes canadienses no son lo que deberían
ser tomando en cuenta el nivel digamos
de desarrollo económico y de recursos
que tiene el país aunque claro el
informe explica que en algunos casos
algunas leyes que han sido pasadas
recientemente por el gobierno de ellos
dentro han mejorado la calidad
y la protección de los animales pero que
todavía pueden ir mucho más lejos porque
hay países de hecho canadá se encuentra
en el mismo nivel digamos que otros
países como tanzania como perú e incluso
y hay en eeuu que tampoco tiene unas
leyes muy fuertes para proteger los
animales pero bueno sobre todo en
términos de las granjas por eso las
imágenes que más sobresalieron en este
en este informe son las de cerditos en
granjas que van a que viven en
condiciones terribles en muchos casos
muy hacinados muy apretados los unos con
los otros cuando nacen los bebés los
tienen los los separan inmediatamente de
sus madres los dejan
entonces hay muchas leyes en canadá que
no están protegiendo suficiente a los
animales y también a los animales
silvestres porque hay cuestiones con los
zorros con los osos con entonces dicen
mejor ya han mejorado algunas cosas con
respecto a las ballenas en particular y
hemos visto que ha habido cambios en
cuanto a que ya no se puede tener
ballenas en cautiverio
pero en términos de los animales que a
veces se llevan como mascotas a las
casas o en las granjas todavía las leyes
canadienses que dejan mucho que desear
nos vamos si nos vamos aquí rapidito de
calor y na carolina faría de saludos de
sherbrooke quebec y si por primera vez
los quebequenses no se van a burlar de
la falta de papel higiénico en cuba
benavides este contacto lo conozco dice
la falta de conciencia social es el
problema
lisandro che le contesta a alguien que
había puesto con respecto a algo el
presidente que es atacado por las
declaraciones así que
no se puede agradecerle a las personas
que nos ayudaron del otro lado de la
cabina marc andré de salé ovular
muchas gracias chau
[Música]